what do you do on the days when you're
just not feeling it those days those
days when I'm tired or worn out or just
basically sick of the grind well what do
I do on those days I go anyways I get it
done even if I'm just going through the
motions I go through the motions I don't
really want to work out I work out I
really don't want a hammer on a project
I hammer on the project don't really
want to get up and get out of bed yeah I
get up and get out of bed now these
could be signals that you need some time
off
and those signals might be right they
could be correct but don't take today
off
not today wait until tomorrow don't
don't give in to the immediate
gratification that is whispering in your
ear shut that down do not listen to that
little voice instead go through the
motions
lift the weights sprint the hill work on
the project get out of bed now as an
overall rule I do not like
procrastination you need to get things
done but if you are going to rest that
is one thing that you should
procrastinate on that's the one thing I
want you to put off until tomorrow and
if when tomorrow comes
you still feel like you need to rest or
you need to take a break then okay take
it but the chances are you won't you
won't need that rest chances are you
will realize that the desire to rest was
just weakness it was just the desire to
take the path of least resistance that
downhill path the easy path and by
simply going through the motions you
overcame that path and you stayed on the
righteous path the discipline path there
stayed on the war path which is right
where you know but you belong